>> THANK YOU, LAURA, FOR
EVERYTHING YOU DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR IT GET
THAT MORNING PRESIDENT BUSH WAS
IN FLORIDA WHERE STUDENTS WERE
READING A BOOK IT WAS CALLED TH
PET GOAT.
HE ALREADY KNEW THE FIRST PLANE
HAD HIT THEIR WORLD TRADE CENTE
AT THE TIME, PEOPLE THOUGHT IT
WAS AN ACCIDENT SOMEHOW BUT
MINUTES LATER THE SECOND PLANE
HIT, AND ANDY CARD NEEDED TO
TELL THE PRESIDENT.
>> PAGE 153.
>> A SECOND PLANE HIT THE SECON
TOWER, AMERICA IS UNDER ATTACK
IS HIS WORDS.
ARI FLEISCHER SPENT THE ENTIRE
DAY WITH PRESIDENT BUSH, TAKE U
THROUGH THOSE FIRST MOMENTS COM
AT YOU WERE THERE FOR EVERY
MINUTE OF IT.
>> AS THE MOTORCADE PULLED UP,
GOT A PAGE, AND IT SAID A PLANE
HAS HIT THE WORLD TRADE CENTER
IN I THOUGHT ACCIDENT, SMALL
PLANE, AND THEN ABOUT 30 SECOND
BEFORE ANDY CARD WALKED INTO
THAT ROOM AND WHISPERED AND THE
PRESIDENT'S RIGHT HERE, I WAS
BLAMING LEANING AGAINST THE LEF
WALL OF THAT ROOM AND I GOT A
SECOND PAGE AND THE SECOND PAGE
TOLD ME A SECOND PLANE HAS HIT
THE SECOND TOWER AND I JUST KNE
AT THAT MOMENT THAT IT WAS
TERRORISM IN WE JUST STARTED TO
BRACE AND GET READY FOR
EVERYTHING I KNEW WOULD HAVE TO
UNFOLD AS THE UNITED STATES
DEFENDED ITSELF.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAD TO BE
WHISKED AWAY FOR A NATIONAL
SECURITY REASONS TO THE EXTENT
YOU CAN TELL US WHAT HAPPENED,
PLEASE DO TELL US WHAT HAPPENED
SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
>> INTERESTINGLY, THE SECRET
SERVICE DID NOT THINK WE WERE
UNDER IMMEDIATE THREAT OTHERWIS
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE LET HIM GO T
THE GYM AT THE SCHOOL WHERE HE
ADDRESSED THE NATION, SPOKE VER
BRIEFLY IN TALKED ABOUT THE
TERRORIST ATTACK ATTACK ON OUR
COUNTRY.
WE GOT THE MOTORCADE IN STARTED
GOING TOWARDS.
THAT'S WHEN THE PLANE HIT THE
PENTAGON RIGHT WHEN WE GOT THEM
AIR FORCE ONE, THE PRESIDENT WA
TOLD THERE ARE STILL SIX
AIRCRAFT AND THE SKY THAT HAVE
NOT RESPONDED TO THE ORDER TO
LAND SO AT THAT MOMENT WE KNOW
THAT THREE PLANES HAD HIT THEIR
TARGETS, THERE ARE SIX MORE
MISSILES AND THE SKY.
THE LITTLE WHILE AFTER THAT WE
GOT ANOTHER WORD, AND ANOTHER
BIT OF INFORMATION SAYING A
PLANE WENT DOWN NEAR CAMP DAVID.
CAMP DAVID IS ABOUT 100-MILE
FROM SHANKSVILLE, BUT THE FIRST
REPORT WAS NEAR CAMP DAVID, AT
THE SAME TIME THE MEDIA WAS FUL
OF STORIES ABOUT THERE'S A CAR
BOMB AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
THE MALL IS ON FIRE, AT 10:32
A.M., THE PRESIDENT WAS ON
THE PHONE WITH THE BUNKER IN TH
VICE PRESIDENT AND THE BUNKER
SAID TO HIM WE GOT A CALL AT TH
WHITE HOUSE SAYING ANGEL IS NEXT
.
ANGEL IS THE SECRET SERVICE COD
WORD FOR AIR FORCE ONE, THAT
SINCE THEY SHIVER DOWN THE PILO
SPINE MAKING HIM THINK IS THIS
AN INSIDE JOB.
WHO COULD POSSIBLY HAVE THE COD
WORD FOR AIR FORCE ONE?
HE STATIONED THE AIR FORCE
SECURITY OFFICER AT THE STEPS
GOING UP TO THE COCKPIT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT NOBODY COULD COME
UP THOSE STEPS AND TAKE DOWN AI
FORCE ONE.
IT WAS JUST A SWIRL OF
INFORMATION.
MUCH OF IT WRONG, BUT ALL OF IT
SCARY.
>> I WANT TO PLAY THIS COCKPIT
RECORDING FROM UNITED FLIGHT 93
WHICH WAS THE ONE THAT WAS
BELIEVED TO BE HEADED TOWARD
EITHER THE WHITE HOUSE OR THE
CAPITAL BUILDING.
>> UNITED 93, 12 MILES EAST ON
370.
>> WE 93.
>> UNITED 93.
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> WHERE WERE YOU IN THE
PRESIDENT AT THAT POINT?
>> WE WERE ABOARD AIR FORCE ONE
WE DID NOT HEAR THOSE AUDIOTAPE
UNTIL DAYS LATER AFTER SEPTEMBE
THOSE ON AIR FORCE ONE AND OF
COURSE THAT'S A PLANE THAT WENT
DOWN AND SHANKSVILLE AND, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S THE HEROISM OF THE
CREW, OF THE PASSENGERS THAT
TOOK DOWN THAT PLANE.
THE 9/11 COMMISSION HAD TO STUD
IT, THEY REPORTED THAT THERE WA
NEVER GOING TO BE KNOWN WHETHER
THE TARGET OF THE PLANE WAS THE
WHITE HOUSE OR THE CAPITAL, THE
HIJACKERS WE'RE ARGUING ABOUT
WHICH OF THOSE TWO TARGETS THEY
WERE GOING TO GO AFTER.
AND WE WILL NEVER HAVE THAT
RESOLVED FRED.
>> THE QUESTION WAS ALWAYS
DISCUSSED AND THE YEARS
AFTERWARD WAS WHO GAVE THE ORDE
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE DOWN UNITED
93 OR ANY CIVILIAN AIRCRAFT IF
IT WAS UNDERSTOOD TO BE IN
IMMEDIATE THREAT TO THE
PRESIDENT OR WASHINGTON, OR ANY
OTHER INSTALLATION?
>> ANYWHERE.
>> THAT ORIGINALLY WAS A
DECISION MADE OR AN ACTION TAKE
AND THE BUNKER UNDERNEATH THE
WHITE HOUSE BY CHENEY THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO THE PRESIDENT, THE
PRESIDENT APPROVED IT VERY THER
WAS SOME ISSUE ABOUT THE
SEQUENCING OF THAT DECISION, I
THINK THE DECISION WAS FIRST
MADE AND THE BUNKER IN THEN I
GOT PAST UP TO THE PRESIDENT,
THE PRESIDENT AUTHORIZED IT.
COMMUNICATIONS ON AIR FORCE ONE
THAT THEY, THIS IS ONE OF THE
LITTLE-KNOWN STORIES, IT WAS
TERRIBLE.
THE PHONE PREZ OF THE PRESIDENT
DOWN TO THE BUNKER CUT OUT ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING THAT AIR
FORCE ONE OF ALL PLACES THAT
SHOULD BE DESIGNED FOR AND A
MOMENT OF HEIGHTENED CRAZINESS,
EVERYTHING WORKS PERFECTLY COMI
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS KEPT
CUTTING OUT.
>> WHEN YOU SEE THE TALIBAN IN
CONTROL, THE U.S. HAVING TO REL
ON THEM FOR SECURITY IN GETTING
PLANES OUT ON THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11, I'VE GOT T
GET YOUR TAKE ON THAT.
>> WHEN I SAW THE PICTURES OF
THE NEW GOVERNMENT, THE TALIBAN
GOVERNMENT IN THOSE LITTLE
SNAPSHOT PICTURES, MY FIRST
THOUGHTS ARE THOSE ARE THE SAME
PICTURES THAT I WATCH THE
PRESIDENT PUT AN X THROUGH AS
THEY ARRESTED THEM OR WE BROUGH
THEM TO JUSTICE AND KILLED THEM.
NOW, JOE BIDEN HAS RESTORED THE
TO POWER.
THAT WAS MY FIRST THOUGHT.
WE TOOK THOSE PEOPLE OUT AND JO
BIDEN BROUGHT THEM RIGHT BACK.
>> I AM SO HAPPY YOU CAME ON
RIGHT WE CAN NEVER FORGET WHAT
HAPPENED THAT D